[Music]
moore park california gateway to wine
country luxury golf courses and booming
real estate a great location for a
restaurant but the secret garden is on
the brink of financial ruin
thank you for calling the secret garden
how may i help you
my name is michelle i'm the chef and
owner at the secret garden
am i a good chef
i think so
he's french that's his biggest problem
he's french so you're gonna have to uh
excuse my arrogance
i'm not cooking with the stuff that's in
there when i lose my temper it's time
for you to run you told me already
earlier you were gonna compete and they
have to leave michelle just may blow up
and say what are you doing you want to
push me in the kitchen i will scream at
everybody michelle's arrogant his friend
she's a chef all chefs are out again you
know what stop repeating okay french
people enjoy the quality of life a
little more than the american
i spill michelle can be very very
uh difficult to work with
jane michelle deserve that
that cannot sit he's got an ego the size
of france as
the atmosphere here is
definitely geared toward a more mature
crowd
this is the kind of restaurant that you
take your grandma out for a nice meal
it's not really the happening saturday
night spot
michelle is having a tough time making
ends meet i can only imagine what his
books must look like only 200 dollars
that's not going to pay the bills again
i have about 300 to 320 000 in that
that's a lot of money to pay back this
is depressing look at that if the
restaurant keeps going the way it's
going i won't be able to keep the doors
open i need help
[Music]
a secret garden fine dining
gordon ramsay has just one week to
uncover the problems to devise a plan
and to turn this restaurant around
[Music]
places locked
[Music]
where's the entrance
[Music]
that's locked as well
god
hey door right
[Music]
hell
[Music]
god
[Music]
where is everybody
hello is anyone here
[Music]
who wants to sit and eat in front of
that fat little bastard
[Music]
morning hello
how are you
and you are jane jane good to see you uh
where's chef jeff's here okay
good morning welcome how are you
michelle how are you nice to meet you
good to see you well i finally got in
couldn't find the front door the front
door is off the parking lot well i mean
i couldn't find it so it's the best kept
secret in moore park
and you've been running the restroom for
seven years seven years yes and how long
has you been quiet for seven years
okay well i'll go and sit in the
restaurant
i feel like i'm at buckingham palace
um jesus what is that
that's it it's it's uh dolly
people love those people love those
really you've got all that fancy crap on
there and yet the glass is dirty
oh
god
brady's almost ready jane
i feel like inviting my grandma for
lunch
could you not have got a bigger basket
i feel sorry for that poor lonely bread
roll in there let me just have a look at
it before you serve it yeah oh christ i
feel like saying a prayer
so um
a lunch menu and a dinner menu
they've mixed greens with sunflower
seeds dry cranberries and montrachet
cheese god is there anything plain on
here jane i think it's all good
thank funk for that
is the crab fresh
no it's cunned it's canned
we'll can that one then baby spinach
salad with strawberries goat's cheese
asparagus hard-boiled egg and grilled
garlic shrimp strawberries and shrimps
i'll start with that please as my
appetizer absolutely
i've got to think about a chef's
perception of food when he starts to put
strawberries with fresh garlic shrimps
we'll see how he likes it he's a
customer customer is almost always right
there girl thought about to receive may
the lord not kill me with food poisoning
[Music]
oh jesus that's disgusting
i'll wait for the next course
are you done uh yeah i'm uh yeah sadly
the uh prawns are uh stone cold and
undercooked okay
uh yeah prawns are undercooked and cold
when he sent the first dish back i knew
that we were gonna have a little problem
yeah i wrote for stuff for afp
thank you okay bon appetit
big dirty greasy chip plate and like a
big overgrown ball of pubic hair
deep fat fried i'm [ __ ] if i'm eating
that [ __ ] that's for sure
[Music]
it's tough as old boots
[Music]
go
[Music]
damn raw carrot finely if you're a
[ __ ] rabbit
[Music]
how's your steak um carrots were raw
steak was tough
um and that was just a big ball of
grease um
the play was
interesting especially with a chip
gordon gave us a scathing review
thank you
it's lazy it's dirty
and it's just bad i mean really crap
your carrots were raw
your steak was tough
and your uh shoestring potatoes was a
big ball of grease a big ball of grease
nightmare in grandma's house [ __ ] me
thank god she's dead michelle definitely
does not respond to criticism he likes
to be the man you seem proud of that
food you seem quite yeah i like it you
like it yeah i think it's good i mean
don't take this personally yes
i thought your food was crap
tasteless bizarre your food was
long-winded boring and just you know
badly done
honestly i've never seen anyone talk to
michelle in the way ramsay talked to him
as a waitress i don't get complaints
about the food the only complaint i
might get is a food cold
jane i'm not asking you to blow smoke up
his [ __ ]
i've just sat there for the last hour
and had one of the worst meals i've ever
eaten that's a matter of opinion oh my
god
you're not are you that [ __ ] arrogant
a matter of opinion not not being that
arrogant if you're such a passionate
chef then you are a natural because
you're french and you love cooking yes
why are you serving
tin crab meat um tin crab the
main reason is because the restaurant is
quiet i buy fresh crab it goes bad
really fast so i have to buy this uh
this strap uh
i'm trying to get inside your mind so i
can start breaking down okay to how
stupid you are
i don't think he likes michelle
we've got a lot of work to do in a very
short period of time that's all i need
is not some form of french arrogance i
just need your
support and more importantly honesty but
i don't feel you are i'm honest thank
[ __ ] for that
thank you for the critique for an
arrogant [ __ ] he's so far up his own ass
he can't even [ __ ] breathe anymore
day two
after being disappointed with the food
gordon now inspects the kitchen
okay michelle's not here i wanna have a
good look around and just find out
what's in the fridges
oh
when was the last time that was clean oh
my god
[Music]
ah
[ __ ]
my goodness me
[Music]
mold everywhere
the food's been in this fridge for so
long even the fridge has now started to
go mouldy look
just here there's like mold caked on
this thing hasn't been cleaned for years
look
it's real mold
it's been here that long even the
bottle's mouldy
places a health hazard mold is festering
so potentially dangerous in terms of
poisoning someone this place can't stay
open
the place is disgusting
maggots
confess the maggots oh god
[Music]
this is christ
hi gordon michelle how you doing
who organizes this place
the cooks and myself when was the last
time i had a really good sort out um
um yesterday yesterday yes
look
underneath here the amount of mold
that's growing
look
it's really important that you're honest
with me every time i say something to
you all you do is smile at me
when are you gonna get serious michelle
i i am serious well show me some [ __ ]
seriousness then will you because if you
were serious you wouldn't be having this
up there
what the [ __ ] is that
that's the uh dark chocolate tearing and
that's how you work there's finger marks
in there where someone's gone in with
their hands that's how you work
sometimes yeah sometimes you don't care
anymore do you
is everything
perfect even in your kitchen i don't
think so it's [ __ ] clean what do you
mean this guy with the attitude that has
no idea what's going on insults me tells
me that he doesn't have to you know he's
restaurant [ __ ] i don't want you to
come and tell me if everything is our
fault can i tell you the truth no i
don't hate them
tell me that everything is awful you
know what i can give the [ __ ] right to
our foot on my
thomas keller doesn't want a kitchen
like this no he doesn't thomas keller's
one of the most amazing chefs in america
he'd be [ __ ] embarrassed if he saw
this [ __ ] uh maybe maybe not this is a
strawberry it was good for him to be
humbled michelle was of the opinion that
hey if i want to serve dog [ __ ] on a
plate and the customer doesn't like it
too bad
the restaurant is not doing that bad
okay i make decent money how much money
have you made in seven years
how much money have i made where in the
restaurant in seven years
what do you mean how much money have you
made in seven years
ah sorry it's a big question you need to
make it smaller how much profit have you
made in one year
you're hiding from me
no not really but you don't want my help
i've yeah i want your help i want your
help but you know i want good help don't
[ __ ] dare start lecturing me what you
want me to tell you i'm here to help the
quicker you understand that the better
for all of us right now every time i
tell you something it's the man that's
just [ __ ] ignoring everything i say
i've met some stubborn [ __ ] in my
time but you take the piss
[Music]
for the rest of the day the secret
garden was busier than usual not cooking
but cleaning
clean kitchen clean food yeah i want it
spotless
i think that the kitchen looked gross
[Music]
it's good to see michelle scrubbing he's
beginning to show some skills in a
kitchen
now that the cleanliness of the kitchen
is up to gordon's standards it's time
for him to check out a full dinner
service
well maybe not a full dinner service
the feeling when you walk in and there's
nothing it's kind of like a slap in the
face
good
customers a little on the stale side but
customers nonetheless
what the hell kind of puny appetizer is
that
[Music]
what is that michelle this is a cafe
canopy yes
strawberries aren't even right there
we've been doing it for a while people
love it
[Music]
did you decide i will take a sweet
potato bisque okay i'll get this for you
thank you
can i have a potato fish please yeah
i'll take a couple minutes we need to
cook it
the food all takes too long to cook so
when i take my order it will be at least
25 minutes before it's on the table my
belief is you know it's nice to sit down
and enjoy yourself spend 2-3 hours in a
restaurant that's the difference between
america and france
people eat a lot slower in france in
america
god bless america
as customers continue to wait gordon's
discovered michelle's over complicated
dishes are taking too long to prepare
michelle you're fascinated by crusted
items and stuffing things honey
now let me do everything
look at the
the scallops crusted
i have the chili garlic crusted salmon
crusted
stuffed chicken
the pork chop crusted and the filet
that's uh stuff i like good food i like
rich food i think it's great it's a
little spicy but not too spicy it's a
matter of opinion nobody likes
everything everybody does
feel free
oh dear it'll be a long night
god this guy is [ __ ] unbelievable you
know there's one thing about being bad
that's solvable but
being in complete denial throughout it's
extraordinary
i've never met such a [ __ ] hard-ass
stubborn bullshitter in all my life
this is gonna be way overcooked
nope medium rare cooked perfect even
with few diners in the dining room
michelle's stubbornness continues to
create problems in the kitchen
[Music]
are we picking up seven oh my god
michelle wants to be the star of the
show let me worry about it please
understood chef i could have been doing
so much more but michelle wouldn't let
me i got you i got it
if a chef is too good michelle does get
a bit jealous
i'm gonna go see what's happening in the
dining room
[Music]
with michelle headed towards the dining
room sous chef devon takes over
i know what i'm doing i'm a machine and
i'm all over the place
and the food is finally getting out
right where is michelle
[Music]
first time you've been here before
first time
i like to go to the customers because
it's great for my ego why are we
drinking oh pinot noir i forgot i think
i know the guy that sells that one
michelle does tend to talk an awful lot
i have a glass of wine waiting for me
yeah
i hope it's
[Music]
no one's taking good no one's got any
passion and if one thing the french have
got is passion air
zero
after observing dinner service gordon
has come to a conclusion
okay so
let me tell you what i
have seen and witnessed all day i've
seen a man that i think is far more in
love with himself than he is with his
restaurant okay
tomorrow we start working together no
arguing clear understanding chef to chef
and i want to see some passion do you
understand the word passion because i
haven't seen any of it it tells me that
i don't give a [ __ ] about people like
you're only about myself
this is all [ __ ] you can do much
better
this is all [ __ ]
day three gordon is determined to get
through to this stubborn chef with help
from a little shock therapy
[Music]
okay a new day and i'm determined that
this guy is gonna finally start
listening to what i'm trying to say so
this morning i've shut the place down
i've brought it up i'm gonna make him
understand if he doesn't start changing
and listening to what i'm trying to say
that's for the end result
and that's a sign no restaurant wants to
see
how your time to work so late
[Music]
what's going on
i'm not closing down
this [ __ ]
good morning this is not funny i'm
pissed good good you've got every reason
to be pissed i'm glad you're angry yeah
finally woken up now i've done this for
a reason just think how bad it would be
for your business to close
i don't see anything constructive here
it's a small town 10 people drove by and
guess what they're going to be
advertising on tv oh the restaurant is
not doing well
okay let's get a big boy if the
restaurant were to close down i don't
know what i would do that feel almost a
shame
but for this restaurant to truly turn
around it starts with the menu simple
food no frills straightforward good
flavor and getting customers coming back
once a week not once a year
[Applause]
hey everybody every time we touch
something tonight we're gonna be tasting
yes sure everything now gordon is going
to teach michelle some simple
money-making specials to put on the menu
okay the first dish should be roast
chicken
roasted simple and bang out yeah nothing
fancy
nice and easy there's a lot of things
just because we've been doing them
forever does not mean we've been doing
them the right way
nothing too expensive
that's not difficult is it guys
trying to simplify how we work faster
cleaner
and better
they're the four specials
onion gratin
tuna nicoise
roasted chicken and a fresh local
asparagus warm tart yes
any questions is he the great cook
no i was voted by chef in conejo valley
[Music]
saturday night is the one night that the
secret garden is busy and a perfect time
to test gordon's new specials i've got
some fantastic specials to tell you
about
a warm asparagus tart the roasted
chicken it's very moist it's very good
it's all crisp and it's very delicious
we've got some customers in under the
age of 50.
it's exciting what can i get for you sir
the french onion soup special the
special the asparagus tart
music to my eggs right here please right
away stable 43
how was everything it was
so good it was the perfect tenderness
and it was the perfect size
is brilliant because the responses i get
off all my customers is the food is
great here we love it cheers
over an hour into meal service and the
specials are proving to be very popular
but orders are starting to back up in
the kitchen
no no not yet
is this table four
is this table four table four what is
table four
people were making mistakes on which
tables to run the food too that's not
right this is not right are they
communicating with you michelle no
they're talking too much not
communicating
all right
okay let me worry about it you told me
already earlier you weren't gonna
compete and they have to leave uh we've
been here for like an hour and a half
and haven't eaten i know i'm gonna say
the communication wasn't quite there
from the kitchen there's not enough
potatoes for the special
there's not enough eggs for this special
and no one's communicating we're telling
you you have nothing left we're still
ordering them yeah i don't know what
happened i've got some specials to tell
you about we've got a warm asparagus
tart it's topped with a mixed greens
very delicious especially they sold out
within 40 minutes have been on the menu
and now michelle's not communicating
we're ordering food and we haven't even
got it
i have a nice package stock that was
ordered for the ball uh two i don't have
it i ate 60 20 minutes ago
what else is 86 i don't know about it
let me worry about it
who's in charge of that dining room out
there
[Music]
chaos in the kitchen has resulted in
angry customers in the dining room how
was your appetizer
oh you haven't received anyone else
no i keep asking i'm getting a little
cranky even though it's the kitchen's
fault we take the brunt of it and we
take the brunt of the anger i can only
hope that you forgive us i know that you
haven't had your entree yet customers
were pissed they were really really
pissed out
all i can do at this point is give you
food i can't do anything else
and now instead of turning a profit with
their new specials they're giving food
away yeah you know what you're gonna
have to hold back five minutes it was
just chaos everybody panicked
i'm getting frustrated you want to push
me in the kitchen i will scream at
everybody so wait five minutes when i
lose my temper it's time for you to run
i can make one shot you want to do it
let me worry about it
[Music]
you know what sell the food i don't care
deserve that
michelle who's just like glaring at me
all damn day
and i didn't deserve it jane you know
what save your words
if i have any more it's a bit
demoralizing when he's like that as soon
as it's ready
okay
you all get out go in the dining room
take care of the customers it is quite
frankly the most disorganized restaurant
in
america tonight pick up
zayn let's go let's go
i'm loaded over now
come here you have no guts where's shane
can't do it james not okay it all got
blown up in our face today i just i'm a
little bit overwhelmed what table
whatever the table is out there they
were getting their asses handed to him
i'm mad because everyone's gotten their
entree and i haven't done anything it's
tough
[Music]
you know cause i'm gonna find a manager
to me this is the lowest day of this
restaurant's life
[Music]
to me this is the lowest day of this
restaurant's life kitchen is closed come
on out
even though gordon's new specials got
them off to a good start the dinner
service ended in disaster and michelle
and his staff were exposed
i observed tonight and i was watching
everything
waiters were picking up food that didn't
belong to them taking orders with
specials on them that we no longer had
communication michelle was zero
i think everybody can communicate
properly over here there was no control
michelle
this is all [ __ ] okay my restaurant
is doing better than this [ __ ] do you
think this is a [ __ ] game
let me tell you now my thing is shut up
enough of tonight i want to move on
[Music]
we will make this a success
[Music]
day four relaunch day and time for
gordon to start implementing his plan
starting with the secret gardens
outdated decor
look around
this is like walking into funeral parlor
what does this do in a restaurant look
at the mess of it i think gives the
charm of the antique
it's not
this is going that is going i want to
get rid of that stuff here we go chef
right behind you there i'm opening up
your eyes i'm making a room more
spacious i don't like it you don't like
it no
bye grandma
[Music]
next step gordon's design team moves in
to bring the restaurant into the 21st
century redecorating the dining room
replacing the old-fashioned sign and
restoring the main entrance
okay good new menu unstuffy dining room
big big big night tonight now get in
here chef michelle with your team and
look at your new decor
very pretty oh my goodness
this is gorgeous
the rumor is bigger we've got depth
and we've got clarity there's no clutter
oh beautiful wow michelle
first impressions
completely different
it's not the secret garden anymore it's
a totally different restaurant
do you think the dining room looks
younger yes it does are you worried
about that big time i don't want to
destroy what i have i want to improve
what i have can you give me two minutes
please with uh chef michelle
the few customers that we have i think
they're gonna come in they're gonna go
you know this is different i like it
instead of helping my business you might
hurt my business give me a chance okay
give me [ __ ] chance i'm not too crazy
about the changes but let's see what he
can do what he can bring to the
restaurant
with only a few hours to the relaunch of
the restaurant gordon unveils the most
important part of his plan the menu
we'll go through it together yeah for
tonight's dinner service gone are the
crusted dishes stuffed dishes and the
garlic shrimp and strawberry salad
and in their place are i've done the
filet mignon the tuna nicoise the local
beet salad the pan roasted chicken
breast and then the double cup pork chop
and any questions on the menu that's
brilliant that's a really good idea
i was concerned with that menu because
you know i'm used to my old menu and i'm
sure people are gonna ask for it
tonight's grand reopening gordon has
invited local celebrities and
dignitaries and one very influential
guest big big night yes tonight is the
beginning of a new chapter in secret
gardens yes tonight is the night we set
the standards tonight yes if we do get
busy we do not panic
all right
now
there's a food critic in tonight
knowing that there was a food critic i
was nervous i mean this is not gonna be
michelle this is different what are they
gonna say how are they gonna like it
you don't know good luck everybody
[Music]
now that gordon's plan has been put into
effect it's up to michelle and his staff
to execute
[Music]
finally some life in this place
hallelujah
[Music]
soup let's go i was nervous
this is an important night we have
important people in the restaurant miss
california has just turned up wow
[Music]
mike
level six only half of the appetizers
are gone
it is so important to keep our cool in
the kitchen because that's when it's
difficult are you listening mike
that's when you make the mistakes
with a sudden rush of customers
michelle's nerves are being put to the
test we got a bus of 24 people that came
unexpectedly a large bus has turned up
from a local vineyard so it's called
pandemonium
michelle can you make sure they don't
start panicking now when we're right in
the middle of this crucial [ __ ] night
let's go over there i need to get
cooking now thank you not tonight guys
yes that's why it's nicki shan tonight
if gordon gets in my way give me the
knife i'll take care of it i promise
i'll make him suffer
[Music]
it's relaunch night at the secret garden
and the onslaught of new customers is
putting michelle and his team to the
test mike
come right here please right away this
is an important night we have food
critics we have important people in the
restaurant we can fall apart
unexpectedly a large bus has turned up
from a local vineyard so it's called
pandemonium the bus of 24 people that
came
it's craziness it's it's happening seven
onion soup buttery onions water in
[Music]
michelle has cleared his first hurdle
and the rush of customers has been taken
care of but the secret garden faces
another challenge
jane have you spotted the food critic
yet any idea who she is no yes she's
actually um
she's actually on a table of five now
she joined four of the people
is that table tennis yes
that is the one we give the biggest [ __ ]
about
honoration bring it here that's for the
food critic table okay in one minute
[Music]
take that out
[Music]
uh
[Music]
do you have any feedback for me
they're gonna ask
yes the fish itself was very
salty
[Music]
thank you very much thank you
table 10 hates the food oh no no no [ __ ]
off no it was salty
[Music]
tuna michelle i don't know what happened
come on guys when some of the food came
back the tuna was over salty i was
sweating i was shivering no but let's
offer them something else i did they
don't want anything else
[Music]
the new menu it's good but it's not good
enough we have to make it good enough
yeah i apologize for that if i give you
uh one of my signature dish um these are
gonna make you feel a little bit better
uh yeah something just to balance the
tartness you know
thank you very much thank you for giving
me another chance you know i'll get a
little more used to the menu it's a
brand new menu for me also not an excuse
but it's always a little harder so
thank you thank you thank you thanks
i'm pissed come on that's his food he's
the one sending it
remember devon out there's a will
there's a way lauren your menu is not
better than mine
oh [ __ ] you know
after over seasoning the tuna michelle
is abandoning the new menu he's now
preparing to send his stuffed filet of
beef and gordon is not happy
hey come on please ah yes yeah no no no
i can see it on your face but i am not
going to start here
i'll let you send [ __ ] not tonight no
way i'm getting frustrated oh come on mr
big chef
shouldn't be in the kitchen
you guys not a chef
with the restaurant on the verge of
success chef michelle is insisting on
reverting back to his old ways and
gordon has reached his breaking point
thank you very much i think it's great
you don't care anymore do you go
straight to the [ __ ] answer no i'm
not cutting no [ __ ] i'm telling you
you're hiding [ __ ] okay all right
okay all right good your menu is not
better than mine you know you're a
donkey my food
listen to me
you run a [ __ ] out of the kitchen look
at yourself no no no [ __ ] off who the
[ __ ] are you to turn around and tell me
when you weren't like a pig
your friend's pig yeah you know what
you're lazy yeah
full of [ __ ] open your eyes
big mouth you're not happy i'm [ __ ]
happy you can get out go on you can get
out [ __ ] yourself you can't get out my
[ __ ] kitchen yeah is it where's your
[ __ ] kitchen and cleaner you lazy
[ __ ] now
it's relaunch night at the secret garden
and chef michelle is insisting on
reverting back to his old ways and
gordon has reached his breaking point
you don't care anymore do you go
straight to the [ __ ] answer no i'm
not cutting no [ __ ] i'm just telling
you [ __ ] okay all right okay all
right good your menu is not better than
mine you run a [ __ ] out of the kitchen
your friend's big you can get come on
you can get out [ __ ] yourself you can
get out my [ __ ] kitchen yeah is it
where's your [ __ ] kitchen cleaner you
lazy [ __ ] now
i've got to get some air before i do
something i really regret
i don't want him in my kitchen
the way ramsay did this incredible
diatribe on michelle and he was just
blown away flabbergasted
an extraordinary day today but i've
never seen anything quite as shocking as
that and that guy clearly doesn't care
about his customers his food or his
dining room just cares about himself
one selfish french [ __ ]
where's the train station
i seriously thought about walking away
but there were other people relying on
me
i had to finish the job
after cooling off gordon decides to
return to prevent the old menu dish from
leaving the kitchen
i know i'll look at you in a month's
time and say you've got screwed slam
through i just want everything to be
[ __ ] everywhere i agree and you want
that to be as well yes yes
every table is a vip table yes yes
jane
can we get rid of that food please
finally yeah for the fifth time
good
michelle please don't panic no no jane
no one's panicking yes no no please keep
it together up up and away let's go yeah
that's for the vip table that's for the
food critics table
finally the food critic was given a
proper dish from the new menu
[Music]
even though the food critic was happy
with the dish from the new menu michelle
was still not convinced you're gonna go
out there and see them i'm gonna go to
every every table when i go to the
customers they're my real critics
let's see what people think about
gordon's new menu oh it's fantastic
[Music]
was everything you're lacking this
evening yeah seriously thank you how do
you like the new dining room it's
beautiful when i ask the customers they
say they love it the food was exquisite
now i'm wondering what i do wrong how's
the people when they're left
um everyone loves it everyone not an
angry face
okay but i want to make sure that not
angry doesn't mean they loved it i want
to make sure that they left and the same
thing was great
but if michelle needed a little more
convincing the answer was in the cash
register you know for 60 customers we
need 50 per person so we need a little
bit more than 3 000 of revenue this is
great it was great to have the business
[Music]
after an evening of ups and downs the
relaunch was a success but there is
still one question left unanswered did
gordon truly get through to michelle it
is difficult to do changes maybe not for
everybody but for me
i'm like so wrong
are you just saying no no i mean it i
mean it the customers love the changes i
like the way the food came out i it was
clean and we made a profit i think it's
exciting i i know how stubborn you are
yes and it's not the first time in my
career i've come across someone as
stubborn as you however
tonight was much better
than the other night
you put your first foot on the ladder
now you got to keep on climbing yes when
i'm wrong i'm wrong well done now that
you know
don't stop
i
won't with gordon's help the secret
garden was functioning as a restaurant
should and as the week progressed
changes clearly began to take hold if we
all spend half an hour cleaning this
kitchen becomes spotless michelle is
committed to kitchen hygiene
he also promoted jane to manager i think
she need the keys at the restaurant with
the manager title tonight
now i'm the manager i am the [ __ ] of
the place gordon's plan was a success
and now the secret garden is no longer a
kitchen nightmare and more importantly
customers are leaving happy i'm feeling
the love
[Music]
you really do have something special
please do not screw it up the restaurant
has improved immensely ramsay succeeded
dude
manager
if we can't be successful now then we're
all idiots
well done it was very sad to see gordon
leaves really helped us
i think we are at the beginning of a
very very successful year no regrets
promise promise still hate me oh yes yes
it was a very stressful few days but i
think we all survived i think it's all
for the better the secret is out
[Music]
michelle finally learned the cardinal
rule of being a restaurateur you serve
your customers
not yourself